[Music]
what I can't believe is I found out just
about an hour before the interview one
of the bruisers mentioned me that you're
a grandmother I am again not a
grandmother let's get it correct it's a
glam mom glam now it says here
grandmother
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
see your grandma I'm a glam mom okay
very nice when you're this young in this
fabulous it's called glam mom and I have
a beautiful glam baby well go let Kelsey
Grammer diaper it that's all I was gone
now there was no audition for the new
normal there's so that you're on now
there was no audition now the the
producer just wanted you yes and what
did he see they convinced him you were
the right one for the role when I first
met Ryan Murphy he he called me up and
said hi I like for you to come and work
on Glee and played this character coach
Roz Washington and he said to me that I
saw you on Celebrity Apprentice and I've
watched you on Housewives and I don't
think there's anyone that can take on
two-semester who is aka Jane Lynch
better than you can so he put someone
strong enough to go against Jane Lynch
and Jane also is six feet tall right and
so I came on and I did coach Roz
Washington and then after that he said
to me I want you to play this character
rocky on the new normal and I was like
okay sure I didn't ask any questions
didn't read a script and he just
basically offered it to me and so and
Here I am well good for you well thanks
so much for coming you look nice to
finally meet you
the new normal premieres in its regular
timeslot tomorrow night at 9:30 on NBC
nene leakes thanks so much for being
here
[Applause]